[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh hello there oh my gosh yo today today
is the day I've been waiting three whole
years for this moment and it's finally
here yeah yeah so right now we're just
gonna hang out chat for a few seconds as
we exactly I'm gonna bring all my stuff
back up go myself it's a lot a lot of
good good times the volume from the
right I got this this better are we
better tell me if we're better are we
good
cuz I think we're good are we good I
hope we're good tell me for good are we
good can you tell us if we're good yeah
little dark when I did wait three years
for this game I am extremely excited so
don't ruin this moment for me
all right so Ben is joining hi Josh
hello how are you okay I am in I did it
mr. Peter can you hear me on this mic
myk's myk's are quiet okay are you ready
to be invited again shoes crashed for
you but it just sounds like it's a rough
day oh you are okay we're going to set
sail as long as you are here yeah we did
we got Peter up in your--in it's a heck
of a crew let's switch it over set and
sail heck yeah set sail alright so you
guys will be able to see my cool awesome
outfit that I got for pre-ordering the
game Mike for non bearded guy
can you guys still not hear me hello I
know you can't Peter hello audience can
you hear me ah
Gucci boys we can hear both thank you
guys thank you Bob Jones thank you
YouTube chat does alia s guy so so hard
for some so everything's out yes this is
exciting and here's why the Kraken we
haven't seen it yet but we've only
played is that what we're setting out to
do Peter how long have we played four so
far we probably played four okay we play
for like two three hours haven't seen
the Kraken yet but I have high hopes I
have very high hopes I don't have high
hopes because it's a Kraken Nick I can't
wait I just want the crack in the killer
I still have a hard enough time
coordinating to like run around on these
ships and actually like raise the sails
and stuff I don't know if I can do it
with a Kraken thrown into the mix oh
yeah okay all right I see Peter coming
in for Ben I'm the only one not on an
Xbox one X sum it takes me a little bit
long all right Ben's in here
hello friends looking good all right
let's do a little dance start the stream
oh he appears he's either falling asleep
again or has fallen asleep
Peter's falling asleep it's all good
though all right let's get going I'm I'm
in alright so what kind of voyages do we
have currently we've shown the last
stream we did we showed the Merchant
alliance so let's go ahead and and let's
do some let's do some combat oriented
one with the order of souls I'm lagging
a little bit same I think it's the
Internet in here it could be what I'm
feeling it might be evening out though
it takes a little while a couple hiccups
here alright so I'm gonna buy ourselves
a couple of
yes ma'am I will bring you some minds to
read gotta go and stay here it's all
good Provo Bros I'm glad you showed up
for as long as you did all right cool
let's grab some some some stuff there's
some bananas here and some cannonballs
oh yeah bananas and cannonballs grab
some supplies I know Josh Shaw's got
that hot internet over at which it's
true also greetings for oh look already
there's a sunken ship right there right
there let's go it's all all according to
plan we we beer use the sunken ship is
to our northeast you know what you just
want to swim it let's just swim out
there
dang yeah it's a bold move all right I'm
going careful though it's gonna be a lot
of a lot of sharks here oh I'll be right
behind you here in a second gonna make
sure that I weigh myself down with all
these pools Josh W in the YouTube chat
said hey can we check out some of those
new cosmetics oh heck yeah oh wait Ben
you know it might be further and I
thought yeah yeah it's further we'll
boat it will boat it look at how
beautiful that is
it is kind of a way it's kind of far
it's further I thought sorry I just
gotta yeah warm up before you you go on
jump on the boat you know ah say Li
sorry Daly my bad I pronounce your name
wrong I butchered it what is this oh all
right Peter are you on the ship already
what's the point of this game is it a
pirate MMO any good ru snark he'll wants
to know are you just swimming out there
Peters Peters going for it he's the the
overachiever of our group all right
we'll bring we'll bring the ship to you
Oh almost fell it's good catch all
righty uh well she's I have an idea
turn us all the way around is he all the
way out there Peter watch out for sharks
ooh Peters killing sharks he's somewhere
in the ocean okay all right let's turn
the ship would do this are you still
here right yeah good
can you hear as well so I'm gonna plug
it my my headset into my my controller
so I can actually join the party and I
can hear okay Peter so I don't talk ya
chat can you guys still hear the game
play audio and we are I'm playing on the
what you're seeing now is on an Xbox one
X let's see Peter is also playing on
xbox one night yeah Peter Brown is
definitely oh no no gameplay audio shoot
put back in and pulled it it's okay I
might just I think the audio is just
quiet because there isn't much going on
hi Victor Brazilian oh just as we can
hear it I'll just relay it to you you
make sure you look good yes I so make
sure I don't talk over our pal Peter you
know Peter is very quiet it is a quiet
boy all right don't lower the sails yet
cuz we're gonna turn around it's real
dark over here you know what that means
all right we're turning our ship around
to come to you is there any treasure
[Music]
uh-oh don't forget you can't hold your
breath for too long
[Music]
here I can turn it up a little bit
actually
all right we're coming we're coming
returning the ship that should be better
turning the ship
and endless this is very important a
very big shift very large ship okay all
right so just waiting for an opportunity
to play my accordion so I could mess up
the volume better oh we didn't look if
the banjo is live yet oh that's what I
want more than anything okay all right
Peter we're coming should I should do
the thing with the sails uh just do one
more because we don't want to go too
fast
I'm only gonna do it a little perfect
perfect oh yeah perfect
all right so you didn't find any
treasure chests Peter really
[Music]
all right go go yank the anchor go yank
the anchor we're gonna pass them all
right Peter your uber has arrived
it's your uber I'm outside yeah Pete
Peters audio is only gonna go to me
sorry guys you probably won't be able to
hear Peter all the water is so pretty
chin guy it's real dark I'll relay all
the messages to you guys where are you
Peter I see him he's down in the water
as he drowning no that's a mermaid he's
good I'm not not there that up over here
in the front that's a mermaid over there
Lexi mermaid
yeah I mean I'm I'm looking at him who's
mermaid is that all right Ben come with
me to the captains chambers as I glitch
across the boat ah my favorite the
Internet is absolutely terrible here oh
my god
my favorites funny all right walk
through a wall a bit let's do order of
the souls the brawl with the pitiful
crew of the silent King I'm ready to
fight all rights let's vote for it
blammo
he dokie where we going all right sure
knowledge hidden in skull and bone
reviewing untold whispers protected by
foe captain dooma dooma quiz Dumon quiz
do mean quiz to mean to me how do you
say it
Dominguez I don't put all these these
hold up dear hold up your map
it's rumored to be on Blackwater and
claw they okay don't mean doom in gays
okay so I am glitching like crazy
sorry chat I just went from the top of
the bottom to the bottom or the top of
the bottom to the bottom bottom again
the bottom of the mud teh this is bad I
can't play I can't get down to the map
if you if you take like steps you're oh
god okay people
Peters on it our internet is lousy here
I'll hold up a lantern all right where
are we going what's it called
there it is Blackwater Enclave it is
north of us yeah yeah
just gonna kind of turn turn a bit to
the left and ride it out oh geez this is
bad oh alright things just so everyone
knows this is our internet not the game
is our tip still up can you guys still
see us should be
reap it raise the anchor raise the
anchor yeah right there perfect perfect
this is exactly how I wanted it
oh oh you did that all by yourself all
right which direction we going
should be like a little bit to the left
and then like yeah we got a turn
actually straight to the internet here
is like really bad right now I know
after the almost label whoo okay yeah
Peter you steer I'm glitching like crazy
there she goes
away we go
[Music]
it is not on Steam no link this is a
Microsoft so it's a it supports cross
play who there's a raid going down you
there is a raid going down all the way
out there as you guys can see all that
cloud is very ominous antkiller 420 says
you look like real pirates thank you
our alas I just keep keep going straight
up Pete we got this headed right for it
dead straight dead straight ah if I walk
slow enough sometimes I don't watch all
over hmm I'm trying to think hey should
we switch internet this is pretty bad
trying to think of it I should do a
check with him because I'm bouncing all
around all right give me one sec you
guys keep sailing I'm gonna go check
tell Peter to do it he's sitting right
next to him
oh wait Peter are you there can you go
as tell you what we should do about the
internet oh wait wait wait
oh no I'm watching you
I'm good I'm cruising this is this is
good right now wait now I'm okay
as soon as I say something yeah we're
fine that's how it always works all
right tell him never mind we're good for
now
now it's fine is everyone buying this
from the Microsoft Store that's a good
idea because it's cross-buy highly
highly recommend that it's in Ukraine
Xbox and PC we're going to the left a
little bit just a little bit oh you're
on the map cool I'm gonna sit up here
and do my thing
what's that Peter nice house
it's inky it's so glitching but now as
bad as it was before um I'm doing real
good look I'm just
Alan liked our hats pretty good that one
what Kip kiplyn I think I said your name
right if I didn't I get flogged brother
IP I'm Kip long that's a GTA reference
that's a that's a great YouTube name a
plus
yo that's an A+ dude Kip Flom Kip love
that is one of the best Easter eggs in
gta-- can you get scurvy in this game
not if you keep eating your bananas
peeling everything yeah you can't get
scurvy but what you can get is bitten by
snakes yeah the snakes were they in the
the baby at all cuz I don't remember
them nope okay so we're a little bit
early release
I believe 9 p.m. Pacific midnight
Eastern will be when US gains access to
the full game right now our friends in
Australia and Japan and Korea and New
Zealand ever all those guys are playing
it's basically a rolling release so
divisions are getting it before other
places Peter turn us a little bit to the
left
it's those rocks like right there my
voice is cracking that's all good we're
just really excited to be a pirate
finally you'll be waiting so long bye
king of the world I'm unbelievably
excited for this game and by excited for
this game it's here I think we found it
the black water on and unclaimed on clay
on clay away okay I'm gonna pull the
anchor one will GameSpot released the
review ad after we've gotten time with
it yeah enough for a while its whirl
whirl just starting off today we might
want to pull up the anchor I'm seeing
more here two three yeah nailed it
you all right let's do this this is my
favorite part when we get to fight all
the skeletons take what's rightfully
ours
mine is playing music under the water
this belongs in a museum
alright let's do it what is it this
chickens drowning save that chicken
nailed it alright see skellies over here
oh here they come
where's our boy at Oh
oh hello everyone yeah all right the
captain's come in the captain's gonna
show up there is captain put a good shot
on him oh he's strong
did your tanking like four of them right
now
whoa got him I got the captain
doot-doot Monique do any clays oh geez
peanut banana after this I got his skull
perfect fantastic let's steal their
skull that's real that's real grim
though all right let's go get more
skulls
I need more skulls for my skull throne
somebody must be playing water playing
music water it's always me Ben's
constantly playing teens dude I can't
wait for that banjo I didn't know there
was gonna be a banjo all right cool
I'm gonna put this thing in the captains
quarters okay sounds good
they'll never expect it in there there
is almost seems like all right I'm gonna
propose the next one we'll do another
one let me do another just want my
weapons around more of a blunderbuss
kind of guy all right Peter can you vote
for this and then lay down can you vote
for this and then fall asleep Oh guys
take a look at Peter he has the day one
patch turned to me Peter yeah the day
one patch fell asleep spit poison Ben
also has it thank you yeah well I got
this I'm just gonna all right where are
we going ooh two of them so this one's
at black sands a toll and
just eat your spooning beater it
literally looks like you're spooking
Peter look it's caressing his head
it's pirate's life for me my do you guys
okay and I care about him
Peter's like I'm out of here man all
right ones that black sands there we go
wait Oh blind man's Lagoon all right you
two I'm out of here
good stuff
all right blind man's Lagoon and black
sands at all so blind man's Lagoon is
right there black sands is up there so
let's go to black sands first so we get
you got to go straight all right so we
kind of like go go up north a bit and
then swing it back and then we'll swing
it back down Shawn how are we playing
the game so we received review copies
that went live a little bit early when
some of the servers in New Zealand and
Australia went live so that's how we're
playing early but you guys will be able
to play in what is it four and a half
hours it's not even that long four and a
half hours get pumped man I have
thoroughly enjoyed my time Peters ready
look at him all right perfect
Peter keep going so we call him perfect
Peter straight it turn to the left a
little bit towards the west yeah a
little bit to the left
Oh watch the rock though yeah just go
straight dead straight oh sorry
Ben's getting drunk I mean to get up in
your business sense Ben are you drunk
nah dude I know what you're talking
about here Peter you can handle this
right I was gonna get drunk too yeah
there you go get some more grog from the
basement having a real rough time let's
drink some grog yeah
man we should have had real grog on the
stream right day heck yeah I feel like
we blew it Peter I'm not drunk I'm not
drunk you're drunk
Wow I'm not drunk my guy's a heavyweight
I'm out of it
okay I'm um your boy is a mess okay oh
now I'm drunk so you take some pits to
set in oh I'm drunk now why does it feel
like I'm on two ships at once I couldn't
grab more you can you can throw up too
if you drink too much so apparently if
you throw up on someone else it will
cause them to throw up to some Oh
real worried about alright Peter I'll go
check the map for you my goodness
alright turn to the left a little bit
how can you see where he's trying to
turn Oh everything's like oh no oh my
god to achieve it for it that's throwing
up I did it alright perfect and it goes
straight Peter Oh God
fell down the stairs I'm trying to where
did it go radium God Peter he threw up
all over me help me
I can't stand straight also who's
shooting at us
is there someone shooting oh god there's
a hole in the floor there's water down
here who's shooting at us oh boy alright
sorry Peter we were just a couple of
drunks where's my or is there no hole
down here it's just full of water what
was it all the way full not all the way
boy oh there's the hole I found it okay
I'll scoop you heck yeah
patch this up ace I'm gonna patch this
up Ben's still drunk God come on I just
I keep like a drunk walking away from
where I'm trying to put the board and it
won't go alright we are just about there
Peter I think it's right in front of us
it's that little one someone else will
need to do this wait hold on I think I
got it ah save the day thank me later I
can't believe you puked on me dude I
can't believe I can't believe any of
what just happened at all that is gross
that was real gross but hey you you
managed to keep your composure and you
didn't throw up I didn't throw up pretty
good I'm gonna keep bailing this water
out of the bottom because there's still
a hole or no no I got the bowl okay
we're good holes holes taken care of all
right Peter we are just about there
maybe turn us a little bit to the left
yeah it's that little island off to our
left there that thing is still active
does this go live at midnight on game
Pass I believe so yes game game passes
it goes live on Xbox game pass right on
day one ready to go
[Music]
he's here to provide music for you while
you well there you go yes for the best
band the best band the best band of all
God I love how my character looks like
just like gross just like I do
perfect oh no but like you know in a
good way like look at all that hair Oh
alright I'm pulling the anchor oh this
is we're coming up right on it yeah we
tried voting someone into the jail not
yet wait no no no one's deserve the
right to get thrown in the brig yet
we're all good pirates here alright
let's go now I'm gonna use the trick the
exploit check this out what I want to go
further I hold down the boost oh I do
that
it's a conditioned momentum and now I
pasty goods dang these are the strats
top top 10 tips to help you top spider
tips it's a joke in the reddit and yes
those of you who have said I've not been
active in the reddit I have for quite
some time now
dang there's a funny Oh snakes snakes
watch out oh good
he poisoned me dude you're a poison now
get outta there he got me there's so
many
think goes away event god I might die
you're gonna be fine I'm gonna eat these
bananas get some of that potassium idea
oh there's a snake in the water look at
this there's a snake went down watch our
water snake with water snake water water
what water moccasin guys yar scurvy Oh
that posed a computer just took just
bunch of both of those skeletons what is
it bananas I got a cool place to be
I'll see you guys later okay nice where
is El Capitan oh man I am oh here he is
captain lash me Bernard Oh No
Barnard take a drink yeah I got this one
this one this one's on me yes there tis
what a boat go found it there it is all
right
restocking some manners that's a good
boy Thanks okay good
so anything anything from you crab there
we go all right let's head back to the
boat till you took the time tent down
what's that uh over the right in the
water where oh no it's just seaweed
oh I was like awesome cool that I've
just discovered there you go perfect
watch out for sharks
I wonder if this attracts the Kraken
you guys know that you contain snakes
with the music right what put the snake
in a crate and then use it as a
deterrent for your chest yeah that's um
that's one of the that's one of the
Merchant Alliance challenges right oh
dang I believe we should have been
charming these snakes from the bottom we
can do we can do it a merchant Alliance
thing now but there's skull next to the
other skull oh wait no we still have
another skull to go so we can skull
while we skull we have to go to a blind
man's Lagoon then we can do one of those
or we could go to the raid we have three
people I mean I'm down to raid I think
I'm raid ready Ben Peter what do you
think see you about chickens but like
outside of having a really cool chick
out there dang that's still really
spooky every time I see it yeah it's
let's see what time is it it's 4:30
let's go get that other treasure that
other bounty returned them and we'll see
what time it is
sounds like a plan and then maybe we
could and like I'm not sure we'll be
able to finish it it's really tough to
do as for people let alone three there's
only three of us but we can try let's go
south to blind man's Lagoon no blind
man's Lagoon I like it my man's looking
all right start raising this anchor help
you yeah mr. X and YouTube says raid I
think we should I think we should -
wonderful hats Thank You Ryan thank you
I forgot that I had this one inside of
my my desk I grabbed it and I was like
this this'll work so for those of you
saying that the water looks different
than the beta that's because we're on a
different sea so there are four seas
I'll show you guys I shall show you guys
so this is the sea of thieves oh right
and so each of the four quadrants have
different they're called different
things so in the northwest part so the
top left
it's the shores of plenty so the shores
of plenty errs where I've found a lot of
the kind of items you need to collect
things so if you're looking for chickens
or you're looking for things like that
like for the merchants alliance that's
where you go it's nice and calm then
down further is the ancient Isles and so
the ancient Isles are also pretty
they're pretty common whatnot I'm not
sure what the significance of that area
is yet but we'll have to see but then as
we go up here to the Northeast
you have the wilds and I think that the
wilds is where the Kraken lives
oh wow and there's more chances of
shipwrecks more chances of Kraken
sightings more chances of storms the
emergent gameplay storms I think those
three right there's the wilds there
there's the shores of plenty ancient
Isles I don't think there's anything
down here yeah I think it's just those
three now so that quadrants thirds all
right Oh careful Peter
let me check the map to make sure we're
going all right way
some danger stuff off to the left all
right where are we there we are
Peter turn us hard to the the right hard
right or hard West
ahoy does he death in twitch what's
going on
howdy are you guys waiting again us yes
the map is the same size rare has stated
I think that they're going to expand it
at some point which will mean bigger
math probably more factions probably
more cosmetic items may be another big
monster I don't know all right oh oh
wait go straight go straight
it's gotten really dark turn a little
bit to the left it's the little island
off to your left where is it that's it
yeah it's that little one over there you
see it yeah
where's the scope but there is still
happening well right now a lot of the
servers your are small
well that servers you're probably empty
they're not small
so at least we know no one will sneak up
on us hopefully well we'll see cuz we
even seen anyone so far right guys not
during the stream I don't think all
right what do we got here we've got two
skulls so far
[Music]
Peter went to sleep
Peter he's asleep at the wheel Peter
come on man Peter no Peter I need you I
need you to get up hi Khalid and YouTube
what's going on man looking good what's
up Sean Sean beagle I like that man oh
[ __ ]
excuse my language drop the anchor I'm
speaking like a sailor are avast
all right ready let's go boys I'm gonna
shoot myself out of the cannon though
cuz that's a good option climb into
cannon Alan Alan says respect for
looking at the chat what's going on man
that's what you got to do I like that I
like that name - Ellen Outland
for than a minute whoa Peter it sounds
real dangerous over there whoa becoming
the cannonball shot me or the cannon
shot too far here Peter you do the
fighting
I'll give you light good stuff good
stuff yeah yeah yeah teamwork where are
they I don't see you piggy here piggy
piggy
Oh God I found him there behind me
what's up camera Schmidt what's up James
sup mateys
how's it going all you cool people
hanging out in the chat all the food
people hanging in the chat mr. x's sink
some dirty sea dog ships you got it my
dude that's what I'm here to do he's the
captain
yeah his [ __ ] your bridle brittle
brittle bridle kill oh he's getting
straight murdered on again yeah oh whoa
what hit me
all right give me that let me see it
whoa it's all you it's a pretty one it
is a nice-looking one I like it let's
see the head comparison ah yes exactly
what am i chewing why is my guy so
disgusting
holy cow
no Peter twice Peter also chewing what
are we eating what about these pirates
chewing this is it's a nervous Peter no
Peters asleep guess Peters asleep Peter
no Peter you're a Tiki I am so tired for
this game so my dude this game is
amazing I love it you get to be a pirate
like come on which side cartoons for
kids hello Joe
hello pilgrim traveler are a vast help
the add more music as free deals easy
and more more songs I can't wait till we
get all star by Smash Mouth some playing
on my accordion says Peter is
narcoleptic which we all fall asleep so
fall asleep altogether now
oh I am out of bullets we didn't count
on that okay
shall we go shall we go to an outpost
and then we raid yeah I say we try that
out let's go let's do the outpost rage
of youth is right in front of us awesome
and then we can go to the raid I'm ready
okay I'm ready to do what I was born to
do I'm going to captain the ship Oh
raise the anchor Peter can you help me
raise the anchor huh thank you
there he is Oh strong guy
what are you strong God or something a
couple of strong guys awesome all right
should all those does get those sails
down want full speed ahead all right
it's the thing right in front of us my
father's my father's text me I think
he's watching that's right wonderful
tilt tilts from far beyond hello father
whoa we're moving quick now yeah man
this is it that I'm yeah Peter keep that
song going after the ship keep us going
keep playing that music sing me a shanty
got some materials off to the left over
there wow you literally can't see
anything oh wait what do you Ryan out
out out there in the office just said
mutiny Oh No why are we muting you oh no
oh no it's still alive
I saw the clouds clear up and I thought
it was done we're still we're still on
course we're still doing good anyone got
Xboxes v-tex we do heck yeah man well
we're still doing good Peter Peter don't
do it what are you doing out there he's
like a cat sleeping on like a post all
right now turn it hard to the left heart
blue are turnin turnin turnin
turns green my favorite favorite fast
and furious was Tokyo Drift if you
couldn't tell captain daddy dabs at the
helm all right let's bring these three
skulls let's go sell them and we'll go
reach it we'll go raid heck yeah I'm
gonna take this one where's the last
poor Yorick I knew him well alright
let's go
I'm right behind you
let me let my father know we're live
right now tell him I said hello
he's a big fan of Peter Brown I hear oh
I've seen a few good streams same my
dude check YouTube ok those actually a
really good like like 180 though for
real oh so you guys can see something
cool
so Ben here has a title so it has his
gamertag and then it's a sailor so as
you play you'll earn different titles
and those different titles will let you
showcase like the things you've done but
maybe if you killed the Kraken you're
the Kraken killer or if you're obviously
if you're a pirate legend it'll say
philanthropy or pancake face pirate
legend but you can choose not to show
them if you wanna make yourself look
like a noob yeah and then trick them and
kill them you could easily do it yeah I
do like the the idea of titles I can't
wait til I get something other than the
Sailor though yeah one something funny
yeah same
what would Peters be sleepy boy sleep
yeah sleepy boy all right where is here
whispering is this them over here ah
they're over here over there we pulled
up in the back Joshua Johnson and the
YouTube chat is looking for players to
play with get in there
become a good happy just a great
community
and just get in there please look at all
that money
weird Pete go did he fall asleep again
Oh Peter Peter do you have the other
skull yeah where are you
she's still on the boat no he's back
here oh yeah was that you I think that's
the second one that I handed in oh it's
over here Peter yes
[Music]
Oh in the meantime let me show you guys
some of the new cosmetic items
hello Caro hmm
let's let's browse some cosmetics so we
have as you can see the day one patch
that's a very good job hahaha
so a lot of these we've seen so a lot of
them we've seen oh let's see she's got
some new stuff so here's a new looking
dress that's pretty cool
let's see oh is this a gold hook oh it's
a ceremonial Admiral hook dang you gotta
you gotta earn the right to wear that
these are expensive these are very
expensive this hair is pretty sweet
big wavy hair Oh check these pants out
this Sansa like nice those are nice
trousers all right Carl
whatever you say let's see if there's
any new weapons let's take a look hello
Winnie oh she's nice this time all right
Winnie has alright still your average
blunderbuss Cutlass the sea dog the like
long range thing loves long range sea
dogs
looks like those are those are the only
weapons in the game so far so pistols
alright
cheerio and now let's check one last
store and see if there are any
instruments if there's a banjo I'm gonna
buy that like right quick what is this
the snake pit I don't think anything's
here
don't go in there that's that's
dangerous you think this is some weird
no no it's normal alright let's check to
see if they have any new instruments I'm
wagging a little bit okay Oh Tony
oh girl Tony Tony is not a very pirate
name just sayin alright so hurdy-gurdy
can concertina
ooh this shovel is pretty that's a real
cool-looking looking that shovel uh
doesn't look like the banjos are live
yet dang curses foiled again nope no
banjo dang alright so that was a look at
the cosmetic items peter and ben are you
guys ready to go I'm making my way
downtown walking fast
let's head let's head back to the ship
oh boy
Peter are you there already I think it's
this way Peter good holy jeez are you
throwing up again look okay yes yes I am
Ben's drunk and vomiting again no
everything's fine alright hopefully no
sharks are here oh you guys wanted me to
try the trick to see if it shoots me
through the water let's see oh it does
not it does not oh really
alright so you have to be on land for
the kind of sword push to work Oh little
Mythbusters oh my god I'm very drunk
he's hammered
see a tiara Tiki asks is your pops a
gamer fan my dad is watching right now
we can we can confidently say no he is
very much not a nerd fan but we're we're
we're showing them what's up by you know
hanging out having a good time out and
and playing and being pirates he paid
while we do it
pilgrim traveler says is a pirate's
favorite food and art it's real good I
like that
all right give us your best pirate jokes
Oh No also greetings to my mother and
father they're both tuned in hello hello
- I hope you're having a good day a lot
of sass fatal gamer says who thinks they
need long boats to get to shore I 1000%
think that needs to happen and I can't
wait because the dev said it's in the
plans to come oh there you go in the
plans I wonder like what what the plan
is going forward you must yeah okay
I won't oh no Peters getting drunk too
now my dude Peter Oh God oh you're here
yeah I made it
hey Peter quit getting drunk and help me
I got you I got you dude okay we're in
though I can't promise that I'm not
gonna be drinking alrighty I'm steering
because you two are drunk sounds like
the perfect opportunity to steer the
boat alright let's see where is the
skull what he what's happening I'm going
dude I'm going in Peter what are you
doing my dad says hi thanks we did have
a good day Oh awesome I'm glad to hear
it yesterday was a tough day in the
margarita household the North Carolina
Tarheels lost in the round of 32 oh no
it's all good we'll get over it because
guess what
Pirates make everything better it's very
true last night you drunk oh my god
don't don't you throw up on me Peter
oh no I fall off the boat sees me vomit
on me he's vomited on me i peter has
vomited on me and been fell off the boat
in his drunken stupor my character
literally just was like I'm gonna throw
myself off this way
where's our mermaid at this is real
spooky I'm not into it
look I wish you could see Ben's screen
the boat is just really tiny in the
distance that's a very fast boat Oh
Peter fell off - Peter are you did you
fall off this is why you don't drink and
boat take me home mermaid Peter it's
losing it right now you cats can't hear
it but he's having a real good time
Peter's saying that he's wasted that's
the only way to do it
alright I made it I'm in back in the
boat I will say this game has two things
it does two things
unbelievably well laid on me best water
yes yes yes best truck mechanics oh
definitely
ah alright is it out now Justin Mariner
in the u.s. not yet almost what do we
got four hours four hours to lunch
all right I see the skull Peters back
hello Peter and Ben still drinking of
course
alright then try to vomit on me again
move in I'm gonna try not so good to
launch myself off the boat again here's
the good thing a lot of people say that
Oh God people say that that this game
can be boring when you're sailing from
Iran to Ireland do yourself a favor
you don't truck got some grog man Yeah
right don't you kind of reflect on
things throw yourself up when you're
absolutely sick of everything where is
he
yikes Oh Ben's trying to use them
in-game chap God jeez I can't I need to
hold onto something
gosh all over the crew alright oh I
don't know if that was the ocean or that
was Peter oh that was me did I do that
Oh sunken ship to our right the sunken
ship to our right it's quick stop it
that's not good [ __ ] I'm trying to get
the anchor Oh six minutes until launch
in the United Kingdom ooh all right
you some more pirates out in the out in
the sea James SS vomit on a sleeping
Peter name of my autobiography we're
gonna go okay we're gonna all right you
two can get drunk I'm gonna go to that
sunken show more come with you no I
[Music]
bought a peg leg I bought a peg leg but
it cost me an arm and a leg that's a
good one this one oh it's a real good
one oh I need to refill my uh all right
we're almost to the sunken ship my mug
here Peter is still vomiting he's just
having a blast oh my god no I need to
clean off
oh my god I think you were throwing up
just now oh it made me throw up there's
some some green coming out of you all
right no I thought let's go see if
there's any treasure ah the wreck of the
damned Hydra damn what do we got going
on in here nothing nothing cool in the
captains area alright nothing here
that's fine that's cool okay let's see
go folks go there just go in here nice
all right we found something there might
be something in the poop deck if you can
get there I'm gonna i'ma head there now
are you still drunk I mean a little bit
but it's not it's not too bad boss trust
me
oh no wooden plank I think it's not too
late to patch this up ah
people are asking kill code games is
there a battle royale mode there is not
a battle royale oh there wasn't yeah I
found a chest and I also found a little
little air pocket so I could get some
breath packs I'm on my way back with the
chest
we missed a banana so dizzy definitely I
got I got the banana right right there
Ben's getting the banana he's still down
there that's what I'm all about is
getting those bananas no no bananas left
behind all right perfect
let's is the skull still out there Peter
oh oh oh no what happened I think the
skull is gone
someone snuck on our boat and took our
skull oh that skull know the I think the
raid is gone we didn't make it in time
dang sorry well let's see with another
skull it's even the Sun sets
Oh let's kill the Kraken if the Kraken
were to pop up I'd be totally into it
you know I was trolling the reddit
earlier and I've only seen one person
that's posted cracking gameplay so far
mm-hmm
so maybe we haven't seen it yet oh is
that another ship is it we've got
another ship let's go up to the ship
if this it's a single sale chip let's go
get them or do a quick murder on these
boys yep
here you guys left the anchor I'm gonna
turn us all right I'm moving on the
anchor now uh yeah I agree with Sean
beagle here in the chat I think the
Kraken is probably super super rare yeah
I don't I don't know how often we're
gonna see it I hope it's a fairly rare
thing but all right that ship is way out
there we might be able to catch it if we
can catch the just the the winds turn
out on TV and touch the winds so they
won't they won't even see us coming one
minute for the you cases loud neighbor
gamer that should be mark get ready to
be my gamertag loud neighbor most of our
lights are off captain sea beard says
sink their ship take them out wow I made
a mistake I didn't realize that this
monitor Auto adjusts so what so if
there's like no light it just gets
really dark oh really
so I should probably turn on there we go
everything's good again hello oh man I'm
gonna put you this one I'm old me
I'm all me hello
put your name sorry but welcome to the
show welcome to the chat I'm all any
money Peter you're doing all right over
there started drinking again now's not
the time to drink we've got boat murders
w is that oh shoot
they turned they turned I got a turn
turn this sail turn the boat around
I don't even see him I don't even know
where they are it's the light way out in
the distance there okay we're headed
toward uh I think they're headed toward
that storm yay
a storm fight Nick B says UK is out and
I'm on welcome to the sea of Thieves
so Alan Ellen is asking do you think
those ships flying around the beta were
actually the Kraken but they took it out
for the mechanic I don't think so I
think that was just a glitch and I bet
you that glitch probably still exists -
yes
Nate Wilkes we are on Twitch if you go
to twitch.tv slash GameSpot yeah alright
we'll play for another 30 minutes or so
that sound good Peter will play will
play on stream for another like 30
minutes and then we'll call it I think I
see a second ship are we about to have a
giant ship ship fight there's one out
directly in front of us we're catching
up to them yeah you'll see it because
the light so I see the one ship we are
definitely coming up on it yeah all
right
adjust the sails sword-catching the wind
which way is the wind oh no it's
[Music]
he's pretty pretty good I'm gonna try to
maybe match it's a little bit to the
left yeah I got that one
I found the right to be tough was you're
chatting about it in the comments the
rate for me was it was difficult but I
did it with a duo there's only two of us
and then actually are the other video
producer Jake Decker hopped in to help
us as a third it was a difficult task to
to take on I will say alright we're
gaining on them this is what it's like
to be a real pirate we're gaining on
them we should I just turn around you
know alright question for everyone what
is your favorite Pirates of the
Caribbean movie which one it's going to
be the first one
third for real everyone well Jack
Sparrow wakes up in Davy Jones's Locker
it's like my favorite thing in the whole
world that scene is awesome with the
rock crabs and he licks the rock and
other things like duh and then he like
he lays down like Peter Jack Sparrow
lays down and then he wakes up to the
ship I love that scene dang
I still think for me it's the first one
though said Oh Jake says the first one
turned this guy's mic off
dang are we catching up to them I think
so yeah all right load the cannons on
the on the left side I'm gonna start on
the other end I'm gonna start turning us
in there
deejay gaming we have a couple review
couple oh my god guys the Kraken no way
oh my god guys go back in alright no
this is the Kraken where this is the
Kraken oh my god my god Oh Nick we gotta
load the kid oh my god
get on the cannons jump god I can't hit
one of them I hit one of them once and I
hit him twice oh my god it's going back
under it's going back under it's coming
up let's go oh oh
Oh God Oh God where you might need to
move the ship
no no we'll fight it we'll fight it if
they take us down that's how the stream
ends Joe I'm into it dude we're doing
pretty well can't oh oh oh God
can't hit either of these these things
whirring what is it about to do what is
it about I don't like it alright for
those of you that were wondering if you
can see the Krakens body under the water
I'm jumping in
Oh No okay you alright confirmed
confirmed you cannot see the Kraken
under the water oh god I'm gonna kill
more him I know we can do this alright
let's see how close I can get to it oh
my god this is keep firing boys shoot me
shoot oh my god how was it not attacking
the world ship however there's a little
ship not how is the little ship now it
was not granted eaten it ain't you
detaining him save me Oh No Oh God I'm
up in the air oh my god oh my god she's
in the water it's on the ship I found it
it's here
shoot the Baths shoot the mouths I'm
getting eaten by it
oh we're losing benefits Oh God
oh this is real scary and I don't like
it Oh God it's gone back under I managed
to get out of its its mouth underwater
so Oh No are we sinking I'm running down
to seal I'm gonna come help you seal it
up oh god oh god
get them where's the holes I'm running
through the holes okay okay
I got that side god I think we're gonna
sink all this we got Oh
we're sinking we're sinking gonna start
bailing I knew I found the other that's
still attacking us I think so yes it's
still attacking us boarded up oh my god
surfing I'm at a motor out Oh God
can we survive mr. Bailey I'm bailing
you guys fix holes I'll bail I'll bail
oh god this thing is gonna take us down
not today the hype is real this is way
better than I thought it was gonna be
how is that single steel shipping up an
attack I don't I'm still surprised that
they haven't come over to like help also
I'm still surprised the cracked it
hasn't sunk us because we were where a
spyro or do a single sales bailing on us
oh shoot up etch up all right good thing
we weren't drunk when this is happening
yeah thank God you guys weren't drunk
okay I'm going to I'm gonna turn this
can I still hit him from here I think I
might be able to hit him I'm gonna
finish bailing the rest of this out I'm
gonna come back this way okay I need to
get more I need to get more cannons okay
okay
whoa whoa Oh guys we survived oh by the
way you can you can 20% see that
underwater it doesn't have a body though
uh maybe I was looking at it I'll save
the clip and I can run it back Wow wait
should we confirm whether it has a body
or not oh let's do it I'm going to go
you're going in again I'm going in I'm
gonna bring the ship back does this
thing have a body I can't believe that
we got it bring bringing the ship back
in I can't believe this happened all
right
I'm headed out to the body
there it is that crackin
all right I'm dipping under so it looks
like it just makes the water black so
you had to be like right on top of it
it's like red and green it's real weird
I'm gonna run the boat right into one of
the arms okay
I'm swimming out to the ramming speed
I'm ready for this swimming out oh oh oh
it noticed me it noticed me it nobody's
man he's going for you you mad all right
I'm gonna I'm dipping into the water
again I'm not oh good I think it Bob oh
you're about to see it whoa why is the
ship stopped eating bananas guys oh oh
it found me I don't think so I think
it's back oh god I'm out of bullets
all right so I don't think it has a body
cuz I'm looking down gross underwater
though not into it I don't see it
oh god it grabbed me again it's just
black hey ya die mr. cracker oh it's
it's holding onto our ship is it really
yeah it's it's trying to pull our ship
under oh no oh no oh no I'm out of
bananas this thing's gonna kill me punch
us through me oh no it's eating our [ __ ]
Oh No not good
we never named our [ __ ] with God oh no I
think it knows we're not on board the
the USS Catherine zeta-jones she's
taking on too much water
what about the lantern I'm using the
lantern oh it's it's doing oh it's
trying it seems I can't drag this
underwater
we're Sun Oh God it's attacking me from
underneath now oh god it's sinking our
ship your ship is oh oh it killed me
what is that green it finally killed me
oh the ship is rolled over
we were messed up we're done holy cow oh
man can't believe that just happened
one crack in one crack and we went back
to it we went back to it give the people
what they want they want to see the
Kraken we'll give him the Kraken our
boats gone but I'm still here I'm gonna
take this thing out I'm not gonna take I
think we're gonna end here Peter anyway
let's see where let's see where it takes
me
I think it's gonna take me wow we're
back jackaroo nice holy cow
hey Peter can you ask TAFE he wants us
to keep going or should we should we
finish on a high note I was like how our
boats sinking as a high note I think it
I think that was good I was real good
dang sea of thieves what should we do it
is still out there oh you can see it
look at that
what wow that just means we've got a
good Rick let's go back again go check
it out let's go back we got to take that
guy out I mean I'm almost on the boat
man those of you who were saying that it
was underwhelming come and play man come
and fight that thing yourself
it's intense yeah what into the Kraken
alright Peter would like me to fire him
into the crack wait wait wait before you
lower the sails let me turn turn us
around yeah yeah we'll just good we can
get there quick
full speed ahead I grab some ammo that
was I can't believe I'm really glad that
we managed to find it while we were
streaming so that's I literally just
said to all of you guys I've been
scouring the reddit all morning and I
only seen one gameplay of it and we were
going at the little tiny ship maybe the
game knew we were about to bully up on
you maybe that helpless sailors that
might be it and it's like no dude okay
all right lower the sails lower the
sails oh god this game is really pretty
when all
sauron yeah it is skin is very pretty
look at that thing
alright and turn the sails to the right
right okay
yes pyre and the YouTube chat says the
Beast must die just show this is the
real monster honor load those cannons
we're going back for more Peter is
everyone at your desk watching
I can't even we're all loaded up it
looks like so that's good alright I'm
going Peter said all the cannons are
loaded he only needs a beer perfect
alright I'm gonna grab some cannon balls
cuz I think I'm out
Oh Peter fell asleep Oh Peter sleep
Peter's sleeping again Peter now you
know it's not to play I'm trying to get
there yeah perfect
all right plenty of cannonballs all
right for all a storing cannon we are we
are going against the wind
so we're a little slow all right
we're almost there
I can't wait to rewatch my reaction I
didn't believe it's just the ship
creaking like there's no way what's
going on we're hunting a Kraken all
right boys we're headed back there's
also a storm dangerously close to it oh
wait did it just go back in the water I
hope it just secluded back into the
water well good maybe it'll still be
there just head off in that direction
and see if it still pops out it might
still pop up because so it patrols the
water so it should still be there I'm
not sure we don't we we don't know if we
can kill it or not okay who's drunk I'll
give you two guesses concert a drunk
look I just had a deal with some real
[ __ ] man I don't I don't know what else
to do all right
the ocean is starting to change colors I
think the drunk playing is enhancing
this
oh my god that is horrible
okay hold on turning the sails all right
we're going back to the scene of the
Kraken you know what I think we would
have gotten achievement if we had just
left it really yeah
oh god Peter no no dang I don't know I
don't see it
where is it we can't fix the sails we're
going against wind I'll turn us a little
bit this way and maybe we can cap okay I
can hear someone just chugging someone
is just chugging chugging girl it might
be my favorite feature they gave Noah
I'm sorry I'm not joking what joke I
missed it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you see anything Peter I see a shipwreck
off of there
I see that little ship should we go
after it again
yeah why not hello that'll be a good
time and this will regionally Wow right
all right so we'll go out back with the
original plan if the Kraken emerges and
the tax again that would be absolutely
hilarious and the waters really pretty
oh yeah drunken plane is the best I
would like to propose a stream here for
both gamespot plays trunk trunk trunk
reel-to-reel drunken sailors where you
get really drunk and then you play game
this is everything I've wanted Oh God
all right let's even catch that guy Oh
what sounds bad and you're vomiting on
your concertina
look it's I'm just trying to live my
best life all right where is that other
ship okay I see it
he was trying to put me out of my misery
oops you riot in the twitch chat says
leak just wants another excuse to drink
it work yes no Sean I will not put Peter
in the Brig he's been a he's been a good
good pyar he's been a great pirate all
right the cannons are loaded good when
it starts he's drunk he starts and
sounds so bad oh no Peter don't shoot
don't do it
[Music]
Oh Oh get drunk in the crow's nest
spider spider in the YouTube chat says
go get drunk in the crow's nest you
don't need to tell me twice here we go
I'll tell you when we get close to this
sloop we're almost there
alright I'm gonna drink one that I'll
refill it and drink another one are we
missing a soul oh yeah
the sails not down thank you thank you
Nicola that's why we need that that
fourth pirate cuz we're all too drunk to
play Oh God
everything's falling apart spooks too
and twitch just said that he would say
half the fun comes with interacting
players
I completely agree yeah I think it's
it's definitely more of a game where
you're like you're having fun by hanging
out with people yeah and it's not and
it's not just hanging out with like
forensic we're all on an Xbox party and
like doing that it's also fun like when
you see other sailors and you're just
like hey what's up like oh oh oh oh then
just fellows all the way down as a bad
suggestion alright we have two we have
two sloops so get sober both of you get
sober i'm we've got two ships and we
can't go down I'm working on it hello
sailors ahoy there nice Justin our
managing editor alright
there's two sloops there's one up to our
left sailing and there's one directly
ahead of us at the outpost we're gonna
I'm gonna pull us right up next to the
one at the outpost and we're gonna light
them up we're gonna give them what for
I'm real sorry all right get ready get
ready get ready
come on okay hold on we've got two ships
we've got two ships all right ready I
turned us too much we gotta get to the
other side other side my eye fire on the
other ship we have two ships this is it
this is art Isaac the grand finale at
the stream I renamed take them bolt down
this is the Chris this isn't even fair
oh no the grand finale of our live wire
on the dock run into their ships yeah
sink them Oh watch out
they could try to board us alright we
sunk one we've sunk one can we sink the
other watch out they might term come
come and board us Oh God
oh he's trying to shoot me let them come
on board let them fight where are the
other ones oh I got one yeah me though
oh god are they sticking have we suck we
suck two ships we suck two ships to
finish the stream it's pretty good
alright ladies and gentlemen let's see
if they come and try to board us if I
die that'll be when the stream
officially ends yes sink to Davy Jones
locker I've got an achievement for
sinking her on the ship
where are they are they downstairs oh no
I'm on my way back all right they're
boarding here is your local Fat Boy
there's about to be your local dead boy
your local dead boy give me some nanners
oh he's coming he's going
where is he where is he yarr walk the
plank
get off of my plane
oh those other guys just bailed they're
gone completely oh yeah we should look
for their on the boat on the boat on the
moon he's climbing them he's climbing
here I'm climbing after him low key
three seven five six seven can you hear
me I'm gonna kill you
where's he gonna run this guy in the
basement there's guy in the basement
what's this guy gonna do hey ya scurvy
yeah kill them hey I'm coming
Oh local local boys here we're right up
on the front of the boat yarr oh don't
hurt him start playing music start
playing music gotcha wait where are they
on the boat where did they jump away
yeah where'd they go they're upstairs
where are they on the mat oh there they
are
let's play music don't shoot them don't
shoot them don't shoot them this is why
this game is awesome yeah we're just
hanging out playing music being friends
Oh
after we sank their [ __ ] play a shanty
with a band of five pirates yeah Peter
are you killing them yeah we're all
playing
don't kill them Peter Peters got a got a
real a real thing he's trying to do
right now alright ladies and gentlemen
that's it we're calling it we're good I
think well thank you guys number one for
joining us
this has been my favorite stream pretty
much of all time
damn I'm gonna say it this was the best
stream I've ever been a part of and I
just want to thank you guys all for
joining us if you want to see the Kraken
scrub back you can check it out but uh
Ben yo thank you well thank you Peter if
you can still hear me thank you
there we got the camera up all right
guys you think everyone in person thank
you we'll see you guys next time
Kubla play a little more yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]